good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy wednesday
on november 22 1963 a man called lee
harvey oswald murdered the president of
the united states
there are a lot of questions about what
happened but there was never any
question about who lee harvey oswald was
oswald was a passionate and committed
communist
in 1959 he gave up his american passport
and defected to the soviet union there
he married a russian woman
and lived in minsk three years later he
returned to this country and immediately
began attending rallies in support of
fidel castro the communist leader of
cuba
in the fall of 1963 oswald traveled to
mexico city and met with kgb agents
there
a few months before in dallas he tried
to murder general edwin walker because
walker had given speeches attacking
communism
so lee harvey oswald never hid his
politics not for a moment he talked
incessantly about communism to anyone
who would listen
and yet many americans never really
understood what lee harvey oswald
believed
and they didn't understand it because
news outlets didn't tell them
instead almost immediately the media
began spinning a very different story
president kennedy they suggested had
been murdered by conservatives
possibly by conservatism itself by hate
as they often put it the explanation was
never very precise but the idea was
always the same
right wingers killed kennedy the soviet
union naturally a suspect
in this crime was happy to agree with
the assessment
as a soviet spokesman put it moral
responsibility for the kennedy
assassination lays squarely with quote
barry goldwater and other extremists on
the right
in the end the coordinated lying paid
off a year later senator barry goldwater
lost to the incumbent democrat lyndon
johnson
in a historically lopsided presidential
election by that point many voters
associated goldwater with murder
as the decades passed the media kept
repeating this lie
by the 50th anniversary of the kennedy
assassination the new yorker magazine
was still blaming quote anti-communism
for the fact that an avowed communist
had murdered the president just because
it's absurd doesn't mean they won't say
with a straight face and they do
by now it's likely that most americans
believe that's exactly what happened and
why wouldn't they believe it that's what
they've been told
that point is worth ruminating on and
remembering
history is a political tool history is
not simply a record of what happened
history is a way to shape the future
history is used to hurt some people
and to help other people gain power
history is never neutral
we are watching our own history being
written before us right now
consider this clip it is from msnbc last
night
in this clip famous historian michael
beschloss compares what happened at the
capitol on january 6th
to what happened to america on september
11th
this was a president of the united
states inciting an
insurrection a terrorist attack on
congress
we observed 911 we remember the fact
that there were attacks that landed
one that almost landed which was an
effort to fly an airplane
into the capital kill a lot of members
of congress
that almost happened here is a terrorist
attack that did happen
so we observe 9 11 he says going forward
we must
observe january 6th maybe we'll need a
memorial on the mall
as bachelor has said repeatedly in the
last 24 hours and very pointedly
we must quote never forget now it's true
it's pretty easy to make fun of michael
beschloss
beschloss is a historian in the same
sense that 7-11 is a restaurant
like a convenience store best loss is
everywhere it could be three in the
morning on a cold december night and you
could still pick up a pint of michael
bechlas if he needed one
just don't consume too much of it it's
not nutritious and yet still an
awful lot of people eat this stuff and
that's the point
michael beschlaw sells what is called
popular history
it's the kind of history that sticks and
that's just the history being assembled
in print and on cable news which at this
point
and let's be honest about it are the
media of choice for those of us who
lived in a world before the internet
their media for older people
for americans under 30 history is
written exclusively on social media
and that's where the real demagogues
live tech platforms are the domain of
people for whom factual reality is not
even a consideration it's a completely
different way of thinking
once you've decided that biology itself
is not real you are free from the
conventional restraints of reality
at that point what actually happened in
a given place at a given time
is totally and completely irrelevant
ideology
is all that matters sandy cortez is a
master of this medium of course
watch her description of the events of
january 6th broadcast to kids across the
country
on instagram i jump
into my bathroom and i close the door
and i just keep hearing these bang bang
bang
i open the door when all of a sudden i
hear
that whoever was trying to get inside
got into my office
and i just hear where is she where is
she
and um this was the moment
where i thought
everything was over
so we've played clips like that for you
before and we've always made fun of them
there she is again
defender of the common man yammering on
about the only subject she really cares
about
herself wallowing around and like me
like it's interesting to anyone but her
narcissism on parade the perfect symbol
of a culture dying from self-involvement
we said that before and we have laughed
as we did
but actually it's not funny people will
believe this crap
some already do anyone who was
physically present at the capitol that
day knows it's ridiculous there were no
rioters in sandy cortez's hallway trump
voters weren't trying to
kill her neither were other u.s senators
a lot of the writers were angrier at
mitch mcconnell than they were at any
democrat
to some extent what you saw on january
6th was an intra-party struggle
not all of it but some of it an act of
mindless destruction aimed at republican
leaders born of long-simmering
frustration
the people who run the republican party
don't care about the people who elect
them
that has long been true republican
voters finally figured it out
it's one of the main things they learned
during the trump years and on january
6th they exploded
lindsey graham was likely in graver
danger than sandy cortez or ilhan omar
they were literally calling poor mike
pence's name
he didn't do anything they were furious
with him
that's not a defense of anyone's
behavior much less a defense of rioting
which unlike the other channels we do
not support and will never support
it's not even an ideological point it's
just true that's what happened
but at this point the truth doesn't
matter what matters is who gets to
write the history of what happens who
gets to define what the truth is
they're the ones who will control the
future that's why they're doing it
there's a reason that within hours
democrats began describing the riot as a
racial attack
it was confusing to hear that at first
if you watched it and knew what happened
we were completely confused
awful as it was there was nothing racial
about what happened that day
claiming otherwise is absurd it's a
fantasy it's a lie
but no one pushed back against that lie
so they kept repeating it now
weeks later it is the accepted version
of what happened
powerful lawmakers just say it from the
house floor like it's fact like it's
been
proven in some objective inquiry and
everyone knows it's true
america has been through a civil war
world wars
a great depression pandemics mccarthyism
and now a trumpist and white nationalist
insurrection
white nationalist insurrection again
it was awful it was not that
but you've got to ask yourself why are
they claiming that it was
that think about it you know the answer
everyone knows the answer
though almost everyone is too cowardly
at this point to say it out loud and the
answer is this
they're saying that despite the fact
they know it isn't true
so they can lump you in with the people
who broke into the capital and punish
you for crimes
you did not commit and never supported
if what happened on january 6 was a riot
and it was
then we can arrest the rioters and
punish them and we should
if what happened on january 6 was an
insurrection however
if it was a failed revolution an
attempted coup
then it's something else entirely if
it's that
then we need a military response we need
a new war
against our own population and not
surprisingly
that's exactly what they're calling for
even at the seeming height of the crisis
immediately after 9 11
there really weren't that many members
of al-qaeda in afghanistan
and the thrust of our campaign there
was yes to hunt down al-qaeda but
primarily
to remove the supportive environment in
which they were able
to flourish and that meant fighting the
taliban and
i think that is the heart of what we
need to deal with here
hunting down people who are who are
criminals
hunt them down like al qaeda
and to be completely clear we're not
overstating this we are not hysterical
we're just
close listeners by them he means
americans who were nowhere near the
capital on january 6th
had no role in what happened that day
and didn't support it
that's the assessment from a former cia
official who spent years hunting al
qaeda in the middle east
no one in washington appears to think
this kind of talk is alarming
in a formerly peaceful republic like
ours
just today senator mitch mcconnell the
leader sent out a tweet blasting
vladimir putin for some misdeed or other
in the u.s senate russia is still the
real threat
not quite as upset about china somehow
but what mcconnell didn't mention and
almost never does
are his own voters the ones now being
reclassified as al-qaeda terrorists
and treated accordingly on monday the
washington examiner which claims to be a
right of center publication whatever
that means at this point
ran a piece by a former cia officer
called kevin carroll
according to kevin carroll quote we saw
five dead in the january 6th attempted
coup d'etat
now carol didn't explain who exactly
those five people were
or how exactly they died it would be
nice to know that
but facts were not the point the point
was that this was an attempted coup
d'etat
and the us government needs to act
accordingly again we are quoting here
quote we defeated al qaeda and can do
the same thing to the fascist
thugs who attacked our democracy last
month but only if we take similar hard
measures
against the enemy within
treating americans like al qaeda the
enemy within
apparently that's the new conservative
position on the riots of january 6th and
why wouldn't it be the position
of everyone in this country because
that's the history they are writing
and we're letting them but we should be
prepared for the consequences
of that history